[Musik]
aufnahmen der überwachungskamera an bord
eines russischen versorgungsschiff in
der ostsee am 20 februar 2021 um 433
morgens rammt ein polnisches fischerboot
dieses begleitschiff der russischen
fortuna sie verlegt die pipeline nord
stream 2 ein unfall oder eine attacke
die von der russischen
nachrichtenagentur ria nowosti
veröffentlichten bilder zeigen auch
überflüge polnischer militärflugzeuge
die in geringer höhe offenbar die
verlegung der gasvorräte partnern
beobachten
immer wieder tauchen flugzeuge oder auch
schiffe in der nähe der verlegung auf
ein zufall
wohl kaum denn im erbitterten streit um
die partner noch zwei wird mit harten
bandagen gekämpft und polen gehört zu
den gegnern des projekts ein jahr lang
ruhte die weitere verlegung denn den an
der arbeit beteiligten firmen drohten
die usa mit harten und
existenzgefährdenden sanktionen die
schweizer verlegeschiffe des
unternehmens acs mussten kapitulieren
und treten am ende ab die gaspipeline
nord stream zwar ist so etwas wie ein
neuer kalter krieg ein symbol für den
kampf um politische macht dabei soll sie
eigentlich nur die gasversorgung
zwischen russland und deutschland
verbessern
darum geht es längst nicht mehr über
1200 kilometer führt die von der
russischen avantgarde ins deutsche
lubmin und folgt damit den großen teilen
der älteren nord stream 1 der widerstand
der us regierung war seit beginn massiv
nicht nur bei den republikanern
der texanische senator ted cruz gehört
zu den wortführern der gegner und
schimpft darüber dass die gemeinsame
ablehnung der pipeline
seit der amtsübernahme beiden spexard
angela merkel unterstützt das projekt
weiterhin ich sage heute dass die
sanktionen ja sowieso noch mal wieder
verstärkt werden aber dass ich meine
grundeinstellung noch nicht dahingehend
verändert hat dass ich sage das projekt
sollte es nicht geben
das projekt nord stream 2 wurde immer
mehr zu einer belastung im deutsch
amerikanischen verhältnis ostring 2 war
von beginn an
ein geopolitisches projekt und die
einschätzung russlands auf diesem gebiet
hat sich im westen mit der
destabilisierung der ukraine und der
annexion der krim 2014 grundlegend
geändert schon in der planung war die
pipeline umstritten denn jetzt ging es
darum die abhängigkeit europas von
russischer energie nicht noch zu erhöhen
und vor allem dafür zu sorgen dass
russland keine finanziellen vorteile aus
dem verkauf seiner ressourcen zieht
ruhigen die idyllische insel in der
ostsee noch zum ferien machen ein ort
der entspannung doch im hafen von
sassnitz tobt ein neuer kalter krieg
stein des anstoßes ist dieses schiff die
akademie kerski anfang februar 2020
verlässt das russische verlegeschiff
seinen heimathafen im 11.000 kilometer
entfernten nachodka im fernen osten und
trifft anfang mai auf rügen ein
das schiff wird seitdem umgebaut um die
pipeline nord stream zwei zu vollenden
eigentlich sollte die partnern zwischen
russland und dem deutschen lubmin ende
2009 10 bereits fertig sein doch das
schweizer spezialschiff solitär muss die
verlegung beenden
es drohen sanktionen us-präsident trump
immer gegner von nord stream zwei droht
den schweizern mit wirtschaftlicher
vernichtung daraufhin schickt russland
das eigene schiff die akademiker ski für
den weiterbau doch die usa lassen nicht
locker
drei senatoren drohen nun dem hafen
sassnitz mit sanktionen und wörtlich wir
zerstören ihre finanzielle
lebensgrundlage
ortstermin mit der ministerpräsidentin
manuela schwesig sie befürwortete von
beginn an das projekt noch zudem zwei
und weigerte sich trotz der drohungen
aus den usa nachzugeben
egal wie man zu nord stream 2 steht es
ist ein recht staatlich genehmigtes
projekt und deshalb dürfen nicht die
betriebe die an diesem projekt arbeiten
wie der hafen mukran hier bedroht oder
sanktioniert werden und schon gar nicht
passieren kann ist dass dieser hafen
mukran der kleine hafen mukran und vor
allem seine mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter spielball von
weltpolitischen interessen wird auf
rügen geht die angst um
denn neben dem tourismus lebt die insel
von hafen und handel
die neue fährverbindung die an diesem
morgen nach schweden eröffnet wird es
dringend nötig um arbeitsplätze in der
region zu erhalten setzen die usa die
sanktionen um ist die ohnehin schwache
wirtschaft gefährdet mich ärgert ton und
form des umgangs ich glaube dass das
unter ländern die jeweils die
souveränität des anderen respektieren
sich nicht gehört was da passiert aber
losgelöst davon unser schmerz ist vor
einigen dass diese sanktions androhungen
das ist eigentlich das perfide an der
politik eher so eine art geiselnahme von
ganz viel angst der beteiligten
versuchen in dem alle e wie sorge arm
ist könnte was passieren und sich
deshalb zurückziehen oder besser
zurückhaltend zurückhaltend wir werden
im herbst 2020 stoppen die arbeiten
daher die röhren der pipeline stapeln
sich im hafen
selbstverständlich ist es so dass wir
auch in der vergangenheit auf aus einem
reinen fährhafen einen multifunktions
hafen gestaltet haben und auch sehr
viele arbeitsplätze entstanden sind bei
uns und es ist sehr wichtig für die
insel rügen für die stadt erstens dass
solche industriearbeitsplätze auch
weiterhin erhalten bleiben und auch neue
dazu kommen weil nur von tourismus kann
man aus meiner sicht nicht leben jetzt
ist auch die fährverbindung nach
schweden geführt
wir sind in einer globalen welt die
reederei die heute mit uns den katamaran
als erstes auf die reise geschickt hat
ist zum beispiel auch in amerika tätig
und die gefahr besteht
ich hoffe dass unsere bundesregierung
erschafft solch eine sanktion abzuwenden
damit wir uns mit solchen problemen
nicht beschäftigen brauchen die drohung
aus den usa lautet jede hilfe für den
weiterbau schafft existenz vernichtende
sanktionen für die menschen in rügen die
regierung von mecklenburg vorpommern
findet einen juristischen ausweg sie
gründet anfang 2021 eine umweltstiftung
in die wesentliche teile des pipeline
baus fließen
die stiftung hebelt damit die
sanktionsdrohungen aus den sanktionen
gegen eine stiftung sind rechtlich
kompliziert finanziert wird die stiftung
von der gazprom pop dort noch zwei ag im
schweizerischen zug der landtag in
schwerin unterstützt die stiftung nord
stream 2 ist innenpolitisch umstritten
die gründung der stiftung verteidigt die
ministerpräsidentin
in allererster linie werden wir eine
gute stiftung haben mit der wir unser
großes thema umwelt und klimaschutz im
land voranbringen können
und wenn es nötig ist kann die stiftung
einen kleinen beitrag zur ostseepipeline
leisten 99% des satzungs textes gehen um
umwelt und klima aber 99 prozent des
geldes kommen von gazprom das ist keine
umweltstiftung das ist eine gazprom
stiftung im grunde eine
terrororganisation die frau schwesig da
gegründet hat nord stream 2 hat quer
durch alle parteien und fraktionen
gegner und befürworter gegen sich
aufgebracht im jahr 2021 geht es
offenbar vielen darum das thema durch
die fertigstellung endlich vom tisch zu
bekommen
doch wie es zu der eskalation gekommen
der rückblick beginnt auf dem
verlegeschiff solitaire im herbst 2009
[Musik]
solitär
die größten verlierer schiffe für
pipelines auf der welt
daher wollen wir besuchen und zu schauen
die arbeit am ostring zwei der
umstrittenen timeline voran hier 45
minuten flug südlich der schwedischen
insel gotland verlegt die mannschaft auf
dem rund 300 meter langen spezialschiffs
die gaspipeline und kämpft um die zeit
bis ende 2019 soll die neue verbindung
zwischen russland und deutschland fertig
sein
auf dem lande deck erwartet und
sicherheitspersonal das auch bei
schwierigsten wetterverhältnissen die
landung absichert das heißt bei einem
orkan bei windstärke 11 hohem wellengang
und schlechter sicht müssen
versorgungsschiffe passen
die hubschrauber fliegen dann immer noch
weiter von oben ist gut erkennbar dass
die solitaire eine schwimmende fabrik
ist die sicherheitsanforderungen für die
besatzung sind sehr hoch auch für uns
das ist eine sehr sensibel
art des transportes für gas und es ist
auf jeden fall eine sehr umstritten
wir wollen aber auch schauen auf die
technik die eingesetzt wird und auch die
fragen der energieversorgung für europa
denn diese energieversorgung europas
verändert sich durch nord stream 2 die
zweite große erdgaspipeline nach nord
stream 1 die im november 2011 eingeweiht
wurde
das ruft die politik auf den plan
us-präsident trump lässt keine
gelegenheit aus das projekt massiv zu
kritisieren für ihn entsteht durch nord
stream eine hohe abhängigkeit europas
von russischen gas mit deutschland geht
er dabei besonders hart ins gericht im
juli 2018 klagt er
deutschland wird total von russland
kontrolliert die bekommen 60 bis 70
prozent ihrer energie aus russland und
dieser neuen pipeline
wir müssen über die milliarden und
abermilliarden reden die die deutschen
an ein land zahlen gegen dass wir die
amerikaner sie schützen sollen
doch auch in europa und anliegende
nachbarländern bleibt die pipeline bei
einigen ein rotes tuch stream 2 nutzt
deutschland nicht jedenfalls nicht in
puncto energie sicherheit es hilft der
eu nicht und auch nicht der ukraine
wer soll denn nun wirklich interesse
daran haben die meinungen in der
europäischen metropole brüssel gehen
weit auseinander zumal hinter nord
stream die quasi staatliche russische
gazprom erstellt sie setzt sich massiv
in den europäischen institutionen für
das projekt erhalten für die kanzlerin
gehört die pipeline zur energiewende
ich weiß selbst meine freunde in der svp
sind über north stream alles andere als
einer meinung aber wir werden wenn wir
aus der kohle aussteigen wollen mehr gas
benutzen müssen noch für eine brücken
zeit und das bedeutet da werden wir
russland als fälle nicht ausschließen
während der politische streit also
weiter geht müssen sich die arbeiter auf
der solitär beeilen denn das wetter wird
immer schlechter wird die see zu unruhig
muss das verlegen der rohre unterbrochen
werden
das kostet eine menge geld und bringt
den zeitplan durcheinander
doch genau das darf nicht passieren
beginnen die herbststürme in der ostsee
erst ruhen die kräne und auch die
schweißarbeiten die finden im bauch des
schiffes statt dort wo rohre im
gesamtgewicht von 22.000 tonnen lagern
der niederländische kapitän kenny hoben
fragt sich oft bin ich kapitän eines
schiffes oder einer fabrik in jedem fall
lastet eine enorme verantwortung auf dem
mann aus der holländischen provinz der
so unbedingt zur see fahren wollte das
ist die größte herausforderung für ihn
auf der solitär kenny haben zeigt auf
die arbeiten an den rohren und sagen es
komme auf unbedingte präzision beim
zusammenbau an alles müsse exakt passend
millimeterarbeit eben die arbeiter auf
der solitär arbeiten jeweils fünf wochen
und haben dann fünf wochen frei alle
sind spezialisten auf ihrem gebiet ihre
freizeit verbringen sie an bord ein
fitnesscenter oder vor dem fernseher das
bier am abend müssen sie sich übrigens
sparen und dort herrscht absolutes
alkoholverbot und das wird auch immer
wieder überprüft sonst heißt es runter
von bord bereits nord stream 1 war
umstritten
der russische präsident putin und
kanzler schröder verteidigten die
partner im jahr 2004 gegen kritik schon
damals sprachen kritiker von einer
abhängigkeit die entstehe wladimir putin
dazu fragen sie doch bei den unternehmen
und den partnern vertrag unterzeichnen
ob die zusammenarbeit nötig ist sie
werden ja sagen und das kaum aus
innenpolitischen gründen bei der
vertragsunterzeichnung im juli 2004
waren auch die deutschen firmen
wintershall und e.on mit von der partie
gerhard schröder bestritten nachteile
für andere länder
diese zusammenarbeit ist gegen niemanden
gericht sondern dient deutschen
interessen und dient russischen
interesse und ich wüsste nicht was daran
falsch sein sollte auf der brücke der
solitär arbeitet neben kapitän kenny
hoben der chefingenieur was ist die
besondere aufgabe auf der solitär für
einen ingenieur das ist ja eine komplexe
sache hier auf diesem schiff ja das kann
man wohl sagen komplex ist es aber ich
habe ein gutes team
50 bis 60 leute stehen mir zur seite
um diesen job zu machen sie sind
eingeteilt in vier gruppen ingenieure
auf deck verantwortliche für den
transport für die pipeline und für die
elektrizität
seine hauptaufgabe ist es dabei
diese teams zu koordinieren wenn die
rohre zusammengeschweißt sind werden die
anschlüsse mehrfach überprüft das gas
muss schließlich unter sehr hohem druck
über die lange strecke transportiert
werden der betonmantel drumherum dient
dann die gas gefüllte pipeline am
meeresgrund zu halten die antwort werden
die einzelnen rohre dann miteinander
verbunden verschweißt und eine
qualitätskontrolle muss sicherstellen
dass hier keine fehler vorliegen
das einlegen in die ostsee in 40 bis 50
meter tiefe ist nicht ohne
schwierigkeiten bei dieser geringen
tiefe kann es sein dass eine geringe
bewegung des schiffes sofort ein schaden
an der partner
auch der ort der verlegung muss
zentimeter genau passen denn die
pipeline darf sich nicht verschieben
durch das zusammenschalten mehrerer
satelliten navigationssysteme gelingt
das mit einer toleranz von unter 5
zentimetern
wenn die nun verbundenen rohre als
fahrplan ins wasser gleiten wird
deutlich die pipeline hängt nicht an dem
schiff sondern umgekehrt das schiff ist
teil der pipeline
daher auch die enorme kraft des antriebs
8 6 zylinder motoren entwickeln 70.000
ps diese sind auch nötig um in bewegter
see die verlegung präzise zu steuern
auf der brücke überwachen auch nicht
kapitän und steuermann den kopf sondern
ein dutzend spezialisten kontrollieren
jeden winkel der solitär
einerseits hat man natürlich kann ein
schiff an eine sehr große schiff sogar
das was natürlich mit mit aller regeln
und und internationaler sachen zu tun
hat von von
von der schifffahrt andererseits hat man
zu tun mit mit einer fabrik sozusagen
wir produzieren ja diese pipeline und
diese zwei welten muss man ein bisschen
kombinieren als als gärtner vom beginn
der planung an forderten die
ostseeanrainer hohe umweltauflagen das
besondere problem der see besteht in
kriegsmunition einer geringen
wassertiefe und einem empfindlichen
ökosystem angst vor möglichen
schadstoffen gab es bis zuletzt doch
nach aussagen von nord stream 2 hat das
unternehmen alle umweltauflagen
eingehalten
hier beginnt noch zwei im
nordwestrussischen kind zehn
fußballfelder groß ist das gewirr aus
rohren verbindungsstücken ventilen und
verdichtern das gas das hier ankommt hat
bereits eine lange strecke hinter sich
die rund zweieinhalb stunden von sankt
petersburg entfernt geht das gas was aus
libyen kommt über 3000 kilometer
unterwegs ist quasi in die pipeline nord
stream 2 in die ostsee hinein und dann
sind es noch einmal 1230 kilometer bis
lubmin in mecklenburg vorpommern
dort wo das gas in deutschland ankommt
wie vechta su voraussetzungen hier sind
ausgesprochen anspruchsvoll das
ankommende gas wird aus einem gewirr von
rohren in die pipeline geleitet unter so
hohem druck dass es 1230 kilometer weit
durch die ostsee fließt in die es hier
in der nacht geleitet wird der großteil
der arbeit ist getan 800 menschen
arbeiten hier holländische und
norwegische firmen drängen im winter
fallen nämlich hier temperaturen von
minus 30 grad an
wie organisiert chefingenieur silberg
das scheinbare chaos ihr locker
das sei die herausforderung an der sache
aber das mache den spaß an einem solchen
projekt auch aus wenn verschiedene
unternehmen aus unterschiedlichen
ländern daran arbeiten dass eine
besondere aufgabe das zusammenführen von
verschiedenen mentalitäten
ketten und nationalitäten das mache den
spaß aus der spaß bei den
anrainerstaaten der pipeline hält sich
nach nord stream einst auch bei
nordstream zwei politisch in engen
grenzen
durch die direkte verlegung nach
deutschland scheint es nur zwei
profiteure zu geben russland und
deutschland offener widerstand kommt
besonders aus den baltischen staaten und
polen
vor allem aber auch aus der ukraine die
bisher von den gebühren aus der pipeline
in ihrem land profitiert die ukraine ist
von der pipeline in ihrem land abhängig
und in ständiger sorge vor dem großen
und feindlichen nachbarn russland
inzwischen wird gesprochen über
konditionierten betrieb das heißt man
könnte die pipeline zu ende bauen um
nicht strafzahlungen leisten zu müssen
und würde dann möglicherweise gas nur in
der menge aufnehmen und durch leighton
wie sie auch durch die ukraine geleitet
werden denn das ist eine der großen
gefahren die man sieht dass die ukraine
hier umgangen wird und dann ein weiterer
militärischer konflikt von russland
gegenüber der ukraine anstieg beim
besuch der deutschen kanzlerin in liter
und war nur zwei zentrales thema liter
und lehnt die pipeline rundweg ab die
kanzlerin hält dagegen
angesichts der ziele die wir im
zusammenhang mit der klimapolitik
erreichen müssen werden wir auch unseren
erdgasbedarf er vergrößern
das north stream zwei projekt ist
deshalb eines was ich für sinnvoll halte
litauens präsidentin grybauskaite wir
sehen es als geopolitisches und nicht
als wirtschaftspolitisches projekt auch
nicht als energieprojekt unsere position
hat damit zu tun dass wir schlechte
erfahrungen gemacht haben wir wissen was
es bedeutet wenn man von einem einzigen
energielieferanten abhängt der russland
heißt die sorge um die ukraine ist groß
zerstört noch zudem zwei die schwache
wirtschaft ich die politische
pufferfunktion gegenüber russland im
osten gefährdet das war auch eine so wie
ich es verstanden habe eine der
grundbedingungen für dieses projekt das
es für die ukraine eine lösung gibt das
auch weiterhin dort transit stattfinden
wird und wenn wir uns vor augen führen
dass wir den nächsten ungefähr zwölf bis
15 jahren in europa mindestens 25
prozent des energieverbrauches nicht
gedeckt haben
er muss durch importe gedeckt werden und
hier wird nord stream ungefähr 55
milliarden kubikmeter was ungefähr der
energieversorgung von 26 millionen
haushalten entspricht beitragen können
das heißt 70 bis 80 milliarden
kubikmeter müssen irgendwo herkommen und
die reine mathematik spricht dafür dass
auch die ukraine weiterhin einen
transitkorridor nach europa sein wird
eine alternative zur pipeline gas
unterstützen die gegner noch streams
besonders flüssiggas das tankschiffe
befördern
größter profiteur die usa bisher von
flüssiggas auch lng genannt vor allem
aus norwegen und holland
aber die usa befördern seit jahren über
fracking enorme mengen konnten den
verkauf in europa um zuletzt 270 prozent
steigern
angebote aus dem mittleren osten und
afrika kommen hinzu
ist das argument einer abhängigkeit von
russland damit vom tisch
nord stream meint ja also ist die frage
was der markt hergibt und das ist auch
die frage wie viele hersteller von
bedingten und lieferanten sie von
bestimmten dingen braucht es kommt auch
keiner in deutschland auf die frage
brauchen wir nur eine autohersteller war
wir nur eine autotypen ist der markt
entscheiden wird woher das gas kommt und
da werden die russen mit sicherheit
einen signifikanten anteil haben an den
liefermengen nach europa kommen aber es
werden auch signifikante mengen energie
aus afrika aus arabischen halbinsel oder
aus den usa nach europa strömen am ende
ist alles eine frage des preises was ist
der deutsche was der europäische kunde
bereit für energie zu bezahlen und dann
wird sie entscheiden woher das gas kommt
die mischung von pipeline gas und
flüssiggas scheint sinnvoll aus sicht
der energieversorgung und der politik
wie verändert sich der energiemix durch
flüssiggas lng flüssiggas sagte experte
sei eben ein zusätzliches angebot
es sah einfach eine zweite möglichkeit
der gaslieferung und des bezugs der
markt entscheiden am ende welche form
die interessantere sei ist es
tatsächlich so einfach oder ist das gas
auch eine waffe moskaus dass die
russischen herrscher konflikte nicht
scheuen haben sie bewiesen am 25
november 2018 kommt es in der meerenge
von kertsch in der nähe der krim zum
zusammenstoß zwischen der russischen
küstenwache und drei schiffen der
ukrainischen marine ein vorfall der sich
jederzeit wiederholen kann wir haben
schon mehrmals erlebt dass die russen
mitten im winter bei minus 25 grad kälte
den gashahn gedreht haben und die gas
lieferungen gestoppt haben
in der deutschen innenpolitik flammt die
diskussion um die abhängigkeit vom
russischen gas immer wieder auf vor
allem um die interessen der ukraine zu
unterstützen
seit 50 jahren liefern wir erdgas nach
europa und wir haben nie einen anlass
gegeben dass irgendwelche vorfälle
passieren gibt es doch eine lösung zum
weiterbau durch ein deutsches
zugeständnis finanzminister scholz soll
den usa bis zu einer milliarde euro bahn
bau von flüssiggasterminals an deutschen
hilfen angeboten haben
ein teurer kompromiss eine
gesichtswahrung für alle beteiligten
einige hundert meter hinter mir da liegt
das schiff was die beiden teile der
pipeline zusammenführen soll
der teil der hier von land kommt aus
russland pipelinebau ist teuer zehn
milliarden euro sollte noch stream zwei
kosten der preis ist makulatur
die verlegung änderte sich wurde
unterbrochen die enormen mehrkosten sind
der politische preis für den streit
zwischen usa und russland auf der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz im februar
2009 10 erklärt vizepräsident pence die
partnern zur bündnisfrage wir können die
verteidigungen des westens nicht
garantieren wenn unsere bündnispartner
sich vom osten abhängig mache beendet
anne ist beim polen besuch am zweiten
september 2009 10 dann eine weitere
eskalation vizepräsident pence erklärt
nord stream zwei zur gefahr für die
sicherheit europas russland versuchen
die bündnispartner auseinanderzutreiben
mit dem ende der präsidentschaft donald
trumps im januar 2021 kant hoffnung auf
das ende der eskalation auf doch der
neue präsident joe biden lehnt nord
stream 2 ebenso ab wie sein vorgänger
der wechsel von der republikanischen
präsidentschaft zum demokratischen
präsidenten joe biden bedeutet keinen
sinneswandel der us politik kam so heißt
die beiden schon zu beginn seiner
amtszeit darauf hin dass er die pipeline
nord stream 2 für einen fehler hält
schon seit jahren schon als er selber
noch vizepräsident unter barack obama
war lehnte er das projekt ab und an
seiner haltung habe sich nichts geändert
in der gemeinsamen pressekonferenz der
usa und deutschlands am zwölften april
2021 bekräftigt us-verteidigungsminister
lloyd austin die ablehnung der usa mit
dem einfluss russlands aber er betont
auch die starke bindung zu deutschland
und zeigt damit den weg zu einem
vorsichtigen kompromiss auf die frage ob
es wirklich sinn haft ist jetzt
sozusagen ganz kurz vor der
fertigstellung noch einmal ein
moratorium ein zu einzuhalten
diese frage kann man sich stellen ich
bin allerdings der festen überzeugung
dass selbst wenn man noch zum 2 ford
führt man am ende in der frage wie viel
gas dadurch geleitet wird auch abhängig
machen muss von dem verhalten russlands
mit der neuvermessung der welt nach der
pandemie die ja anschub gegeben hat auch
die energie und klimapolitischen
beziehungen neu zu ordnen lassen sich
diese geopolitischen und georg
ökonomischen bedingungen überhaupt nicht
mehr trennen und es über allem steht die
auseinandersetzung wer kontrolliert
dieser netzwerke die vereinigten staaten
mit ihrem anspruch america ist beck
wollen diese kontrollieren sie wollen
russland und auch china zurück bringen
und die europäer haben ihren platz da
noch nicht wirklich gefunden weil sie in
dieser frage genau so zerstritten sind
wie in vielen anderen
der kompromiss zur fertigstellung könnte
also in einer vereinbarung über die
liefermengen und einer einbeziehung der
ukraine liegen die sanktionen gegen die
nord stream zwei ag und die
verantwortlichen hat präsident biden
ausgesetzt allerdings sind sie auf
wiedervorlage rügen und der hafen
sassnitz sind zunächst aus dem blick der
weltmächte geraten die politik spielt
sich nun auf allerhöchster ebene ab
derweil verlegen die russischen schiffe
die letzten kilometer der gaspipeline
liegen die letzten rohre in der ostsee
könnte sich bald kaum jemand daran
erinnern dass sassnitz einmal im
blickpunkt der weltmächte stand